hey francis do you want to keep your
online activity
private yes i don't want anyone to know
i
secretly watch bbc comedy embarrassing
that's why you need surf shark vpn how
can shark
surf shut up surfshark is a virtual
private network
available as an easy to use app and
browser extension that lets you place
your laptop or phone
anywhere in the world allowing you to
access the internet as if you were in
another country
this means i can access a whole host of
websites
that i wouldn't be able to access in the
uk not only that
you can protect your online identity by
masking your true ip address
with surfshark you can protect yourself
from data theft
tracking surveillance and commercial
targeting and it's
great value for money because one
surfshark account can be used on
multiple devices
so you can access problematic content
wherever you are and by problematic
content we do mean trigonometry click
the link below
and use our code trigonometry to get
83 off plus three extra months for free
surfshark also offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee
so there's no risk to trying it out for
yourself click the link below and use
our code
trigonometry to get 83 off
plus three extra months for free they're
very
judgmental and they've decided that this
is a racist country i don't know why
they decided but i have my suspicions
that when i look at them and i
see stanford professors or something
they feel
they're not innately racist they just
are culturally
if they see an african-american
professor they're okay with them if he's
in a certain income bracket
he has a certain patois if they say a
poor black person or middle class
they're they just avoid them and they
feel terrible about it they feel so
terrible that they're going to go tell
you know bob jones in alabama on a
a forklift that he's the problem his
racism
is the problem in america he has nothing
his kids can't get affirmative action
they've never
nobody's been a colleague in his entire
life but he's the problem
no the problem is white wealthy liberals
who will not integrate tutor assimilate
people
there are the other or won't adopt
policies that make it possible to do so
because they're never subject to the
consequences of their own ideology
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
frances foster
i'm constant and kitten and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
a fascinating person we have for you
today he's an american historian
commentator and author including of his
upcoming book the dying citizen
professor victor davis hanson welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
it's a great pleasure to have you on and
uh one of the reasons we're especially
keen to speak with you is
you know we talk a lot on the show about
wokeness and all this other sort of
stuff that's day-to-day the day-to-day
of politics but we're always so happy to
have historians on the show because we
think that
you offer a broader perspective that's
often very
instructive as to the time that we're in
at the moment
so let me get straight into it what is
the best historical parallel for the
moment that we are living through
over the last five years in the west
particularly in the anglosphere
a lot of uh ancient and modern and even
contemporary parallels
the lucidity the historian thucydides
recounts a moment of madness that took
place
on the island of corsair in 427 bc it's
called the stasis at corsaira
it's modern corfu when political
differences
morphed into tribal differences to
ideological differences to class
differences and people started really
resorting to violence they
changed the language and people who were
moderate or
circumspect or calling for calm were the
first to be
killed we had the same thing in periods
of 19 i guess to say the
so-called reign of terror this summer of
1793 when the jacobins hijacked the
french revolution
robespierre his brother and others and
people who had seemed revolutionary and
were not satisfied with a constitutional
republic
maybe people like danton or even st
juice
all of these people were done away with
as the revolution took on a life of its
own they renamed
the days of the month the founding date
of france
uh the months of the year months of the
year
et cetera religion they worshipped a new
god they
toppled statues they went after uh
religious institutions
clerics nuns in our country
during the mccarthy period because of
the sudden
um defection of our so-called ally
it was never a defection but we were
very naive about the soviet union during
the war time alliance suddenly we found
out it was a monstrous
country and it absorbed all of eastern
europe in violation of its oath
and then it had spawned uh communist
china
and the loss of china who lost china in
that
furor that began with the cold war there
were people in the state department who
had very naively
green lighted a lot of the soviet
influence
and there became sort of a witch hunt
witch hunt's not the right word because
there were not witches and say them but
there were communists
in our state department but not to the
degree that the hysteria suggested and
finally
you know i can remember a little boy out
in a rural out here where i am today in
the same house getting
something in the mail and it was all in
pink and it said did you know your local
assemblyman as a communist
and what are you going to do about it so
there was a hysteria that gripped that
and then that ended so we have the
democratic society's tocqueville
democracy in america if you remember he
warned about that and why a
constitutional republic was essential
and political scientists from aristotle
to
machiavelli to tocqueville have warned
us
that in a democratic radically populist
egalitarian society without checks and
violence
it's very easy to convince the majority
you know herodotus said when the
persians came when the ionian greeks
came to greece and they wanted help
and that was a very controversial thing
to send mainland greeks who were
impoverished to go
fight persians all the way across the
eugene it was easier he said to convince
thirty thousand and democratic athens in
a few oligarchs in that in sparta
meaning that once the hysteria sets in
it's like a wave
and professor hansen there will be
people who say well hang on a second
you know the examples that you've given
people have died
and so on and so forth aren't we over
egging the pudding somewhat
uh well we're we're looking at hindsight
i don't know how this is going to end
whether it's going to end like corsaira
or it's going to end like the reign of
terror or it's going to end like the
mccarthy period when people just said
remember the army council joseph welch
uh finally testified before congress
mccarthy said i have in my hand the list
of 200 communists and
uh and he said have you no decency sir
and that was a sort of like taking a
hammer to crystal just shattered him
and i don't know if people are going to
do that so i don't know how this is
going to end up
i can tell you that in this country
right now
there is a hysteria
and most people are against it
and the people who are promulgating the
world movement know that
and they feel that their
influence in social media silicon valley
wall street the corporate board room the
campus
hollywood professional sports the
federal bureaucracy
are such that they do not need 51
of support that they can through
commercials or
communications they can create a sense
that it's inevitable
and when i say it i'm talking about the
ability
i work at stanford university and
i saw what happens in my case they went
after me they went after scott atlas my
colleague at the hoover institution they
went after the distinguished historian
from great britain neil ferguson
they go after anybody they being the
faculty senate the professors
go after anybody who suggests that
the united states was making enormous
progress in racial harmony
that it's the fairest most secure
affluent country in the world
it's the only multiracial democracy
that's really worked brazil and india
may be
coming a distant second and third but it
requires people to have allegiance to an
idea
of a racially uh irrelevant society that
your first loyalty is
just is to the idea of america and that
your own ethnic appearance is
incidental not essential to your persona
and professor hanson you use the word
hysteria
what do you mean by this can we break
this apart what do you mean by the
hysteria
and what is the cause of this hysteria
as you say well
we can see the cause and the effect
yesterday in san francisco
uh people there who had been supported
all of this
uh there was a poll taken 40 percent of
san
expressed a desire to leave their
liberal city not because of
conservatives not because of the police
because there's rampant
chaos what do they mean by that they
mean that target
that walgreens are not are pulling out
they're either shutting the stores or
they're having limited hours now why are
they doing that
because ideologically left-wing people
believe
that the district attorney who was the
child of 60s
revolutionaries and the police
department either can't or won't
prosecute climbs for ideological reasons
that e
people of color if they commit crimes
that's a method of redistribution and
social justice getting back at the
system
so the hysteria is you you're in
walgreens somebody's taking a picture
an african-american youth goes into a
bicycle goes into the store
robs everything in front of the security
guard and the reporter
they film it they put it on youtube and
then everybody said that's just
incidental it's not essential to who we
are and then
a week later you have neiman marcus at
the heart of san francisco in union
square
an upscale very luxury orientated
boutique and these are not essentials
like food
these are handbag gucci's things and all
of a sudden 10 or 12
african-american youth come in they loot
they come out they jump in the cars and
there's no consequences
and i'm not being racially
interested in in crime except that that
there on
that was the description of the
criminals and the
idea is that the state is incapable
of saying we have an epidemic that 100
people were shot in chicago over 4th of
july
and 16 were killed and 400 people were
shot in the united states
and 150 died in the last four days we
are incapable
of saying this is primarily an inner
city phenomenon of people of color
shooting people of color and they need
help to say what i
just did would have my email filled
getting to your question
with you are a racist i am going to
contact stanford
university i'm going to write the hoover
institution you're going to and i'm
going to get a call from that i probably
will from this interview
and i'm not exaggerating my colleague
scott atlas was put on probation his
pay was suspended for suggesting
suggesting
that dr fauci's guidelines were porous
and that it would be much better to
focus
resources on elderly communities
and the elderly and long-term health
care facilities but not
quarantine everybody that got him into
trouble everybody understands this that
the military the central intelligence
agency the
fbi and i'm talking you know whether
it's chairman of the joint chiefs who
gives a lecture on woke recommended
reading
chief of naval operations john brennan
james clapper james comey
nobody has the traditional reference
that this person is
non-political they're a professional
their job is to
protect the united states through
intelligence or security they don't
believe that anymore
because they feel that they've been woke
and you said that you have
you don't know if this if we've reached
in
so we don't know if this is peak work
for example
but do you think we've reached the peak
of this kind of hysteria or do you
actually think that we have some way to
go
when i put it this way in 1917 a very
small minority
who had no popular support in russia
the bolsheviks upper middle class kids
linen was upper middle they were all
that way they
and they had thugs around them stalin
was a bank robber
people like that but they were not a
majority the mensheviks had the majority
the white russians had the majority the
constitutional reformers had the
majority the old czars aristocracy
were part of this anti-czarist coalition
and they were hijacked successfully by
the bolsheviks because they understood
that violence
and blacklisting and killing their
opponents were something that their
opponents would not match tit-for-tat
and they terrorize people when they
tried it earlier in the french
revolution it didn't work the thermadors
came in one night and did the same thing
to them i'm not suggesting that's a
solution but
it petered out i don't know what's going
to happen
but i will say that we're starting to
see
in reaction specifically your question
school boards
where children were taught you know
you you're you live in a racist country
it was always racist your founding
documents are racist you need to have
public expiation and penance
to don't do that anymore we don't want
to talk about race we want to be
ecumenical
we want to be racially blind we believe
in martin luther king not malcolm x
so we don't we want you math to teach
math and science and literature but
and these protests are sweeping the
country now at
school boards and recall we have more
recall elections of board members
and in my case just talk about something
that's idiosyncratic and irrelevant but
neil ferguson and scott atlas and i that
were brought up on
charges of writing things that were
hostile to joe biden or endangering
public safety by medical recommendations
or in the case of neil
uh writing an email was considered
rude or i don't know what to a a private
email to a student
that where those charges were
unsuccessful they couldn't get
they couldn't pursue them and so i think
there is a push back
and a lot of people are angry and where
how in our country how that works is we
have elections
every two years presidential elections
what we call midterm where one third of
the senate turns over and
all 435 house seats
so when donald trump is considered by
the media to be an existential threat
two years later he lost the house when
barack obama's
health care obamacare enraged the
country because of the cost and the poor
services in 2010 he
lost 63 seats in the house so if there's
going to be
a peak woke backlash we will see it
in 16 months in the house and if they
win the house they be in the republican
party
then barack obama
is the model for joe biden he'll be joe
biden will be a president of executive
orders he will have no ability to get
any legislation
woke legislation through so we'll see
it's an interesting i want to take the
conversation back a little bit to the
sort of eagle eye view
of the situation that we started with
you wouldn't know this but i am
originally from the soviet union myself
i was born in russia
many of my family are from ukraine and i
was just in ukraine visiting my
grandmother who's 95 years old
she was alive during the time of the
purges she was alive during that whole
period
and she was telling me how when she was
a student at school
uh the teacher would come in once every
few months and say children turn
turn to page 34 of your russian
literature book
and cross out this name this man is now
enemy of the people
now the other point you mentioned was
about the
the teaching of the idea that our
in your case your country but broadly
speaking our civilization
uh is evil based and founded on
prejudice and bigotry and so on and so
forth
uh is there a historical precedent or
historical example of a civilization
that has done
this before that has some point just
decided that
actually it's evil it's bad it's wrong
and decided to indoctrinate the next
generation
to hate their own country well you
mentioned the soviet union as you know
soviet ideologically
ideology and maoist ideology
assumed it was a little different than
ours that
the previous system of government was
evil
and it wasn't nationally i mean
nationalism was evil patriotism was evil
and they were there was a new man that
was created in 1917
or 1947. we have something like that in
the united states every time that we
have a conservative president he is
hated
and then when he is out of office
and people do not want that hate
reciprocated to a democratic presence so
if ronald reagan's present for eight
years
and george h.w bush is for four and then
we have bill clinton everybody says well
they're going to do to us what we did to
them they said reagan was a great guy
actually we're going to name their
airport
in washington after george h.w bush was
a great guy we're going to name an
airport
texas after and then it starts then w
bush is a war criminal
a nazi and now what is w bush we don't
want to
call people nazis not when barack
obama's president
george w bush was a reasonable person
and now he's a saint he's against trump
and now trump is hated he's a monster
and now people are saying well he's
not on social media anymore and you know
what i'm a little bit
worried about the president it seems a
little scary that he's joe
biden rather than just not donald trump
and so that's what we do in our country
we kind of rewrite the past with the
iconicalism we're seeing
it's getting ridiculous nobody has told
me what's wrong with miguel cervantes
and el cid his statue was toppled
nobody's told me what frederick douglass
did long or abraham lincoln
sometimes it's quite out of shakespeare
you know when julius caesar when they
get
the wrong sena not the conspiracists but
the poet and they
kill him the name the
the iconoclast actually went in to a
park
and destroyed the statue of j.c lee the
world war
ii army general who was in charge of
logistics
uh for the normandy and then subsequent
european campaigns
and they thought it was robert e lee
they don't look anything alike but lee
is all these ignorant generations know
remember this this is a part of the
educational system where you're
combining ignorance and arrogance
among young people so they all say well
you know like if you're asked them
as there was a people are doing that
frequently
are you proud of the united
maybe and i don't st like it's racist or
like like
can you specifically tell me where it is
racist
identify what manifest symptom you see
what document makes us racist there's
just a blank stare
and that that's very soviet or miles
trait i'm
expecting the maoist dunce caps pretty
soon where people who object in class
will have to sit in the back
and wear a cone on their head or or
they're persecuted for wearing
eyeglasses or something and professor
hansen how did we
get here and you know whenever we ask
people this question they always come
out with foucault and this and that
and post-modernism blah blah blah which
is all fine it's all well and good and
i'm sure that's a part of it
but the question for me much more
interestingly i think is
why are particularly young people but we
as a society more generally
susceptible to these ideas right here
right now
is it the fact that you talked recently
in one of your
lectures about the erosion of the middle
class that's happened over the last 40
and 50 years
the fact that young people don't have
access to the only form of capital that
poorer people traditionally ever had
access to which is housing
is is that really what's driving this a
generation of people who don't see a
better future for themselves
and as a result they're not really
attached to anything and therefore they
are vulnerable to to this sort of
ideology
yeah i think what you're talking about
are two things there's proximate
immediate causes
imagine an ied what what sets an ied off
at that moment
versus what's the technology or the
desire to build it which is long and
coming
so you're correct people have said well
there was a frankfurt school and then
there was gramski and there was
post-structurals and post-modernism and
academy
and it was all anti-western and it was
all based on this romance about
you know going back to rousseau and
dryden about the noble savvy all this
stuff okay
and then there was structural
transformations in america
and one of the things is that all the
traditional
catalysts for what i would call
traditionalism were eroded
we have 1.7 trillion dollars in
collective
student debt and they're they're
carrying about 30
and they're not all subsidized these
were outsourced to big banks and they're
they're paying
seven percent on some of these loans and
there are
bas especially in the social sciences
environmental sciences
humanities were not competitive in other
words employers looked at them and said
i don't see a guy with a ba
any better writer analyst or thinker
than a guy with a high school diploma
and these are i'm talking now about the
blm and
antifa especially profiles of kind of
woke people that are half educated
enough to know that
the politics but they don't have the
skills and they're angry so what do they
do they can't buy a house
they don't get married if at all but
they're not until their 30s
they don't have children until their 30s
and when you look at the data
people were getting married 23 24 one or
two children
26 27 now that's 35 37 and maybe not
even a house
so and those are we know from data that
that creates traditionalism when you
have to
divert attention from you to your
children to your spouse to your house
that's one thing the middle class and
you're right and then another thing of
course was
we have a new tribalism partly because
we went from a binary 90
to 10 10 percent black and assimilated
19
90 of so-called white and sometimes it
was kind of ridiculous if you were
armenian you weren't white
or arab america you weren't white or
near eastern you weren't white or
mexican and then suddenly italians were
you were white whatever that meant it
was based on success
and even asians you could be if you were
the you know ophthalmologist making 150
000
from korean you were white so white
didn't have anything to do
with skin color in america anymore it
was a
state of mind but the african-american
minority had not
progressed as rapidly although it was
assimilating very very successfully the
last 20 years
so that was another question that we
started to identify by our tribal
uh loyalties i think that started with
obama when he created this word
or i guess the mainstream diversity
which meant
suddenly class didn't matter that you
could be from india and you could be
worth 150
million dollars or an argentine lawyer
or you could be a spanish aristocrat
but if you were not white or you killed
your r's or you had a funny last name
you were a oppressed even though you
were privileged so we got this
ridiculous thing in america where oprah
from her 90 million dollar mansion talks
to
meghan markle at her 15 million 15
million dollar mansion in montecito and
they're both victims as michelle and
barack from their 15 million dollar
mansion at martha's vineyards weigh in
so that's the tribalism
and then we had globalization and
enriched our sort of like what you're
expecting
experiencing with london and rural
britain we had with the coast
silicon valley the major research
universities
hollywood looked to asia we had boston
to miami
looking toward europe and south america
and
anybody who had skills that could be
replicated globally
lawyers media academics
insurance corporate investors became
staggering rich beyond our wild
imagination
you know not just multi-million but
multi-billion dollars and anybody in the
middle whose
labor could be xerox lathe worker
auto worker a small farmer they were
sort of
redundant and we kind of created a
juxtaposed cause and effect well they
left the jobs left because you were on
meth
or you were a dead ender or you were
dragged or deplorable are we redeemable
or a clinger
or a chump i'm just quoting directly now
from hillary clinton barack obama
and joe biden and then when you add in
we have this elite this global elite
that were really revolutionary
and i mean that sincerely that's just
not invective they really did want to
they do want to end the electoral
college they're within one vote of doing
that
if they can get a senator from arizona
to
end the filibuster they will end the
electoral college
and they may be able to do it without a
senatorial degree much less a
constitutional they want to pack the
court after 150 years
to 15 justices to get a liberal
progressive majority by fiat
they want to let in two new states after
60 years they want to end 180 year
filibuster so they're
truly evolutionaries revolutionaries
evolutionaries and then finally
as i said globalism got rid of the idea
and you add all of those together with
this what we were talking earlier
about these ideologies and then we come
to 2000
20. we could have survived the pandemic
and the lie that
this thing came from a bat or a pangolin
when we had a level four biology lab
just
at ground zero run by the chinese
military and indirectly funded in some
sense by
american government officials like
anthony fauci
but when you we lied about the origins
we
scared people and then we had a real
pandemic it wasn't
a construct 600 000 people died
and we had our first national quarantine
we've never reacted that way to any type
of plague
we made fun of the idea of herd immunity
it didn't exist suddenly
and we didn't really protect our elderly
as we if you try to protect everything
as you know from military history you
protect nothing
so we didn't protect the people who were
vulnerable but we did protect everybody
many of whom were not vulnerable
especially those under 18
and then we had a first artificially
induced recession we've never done that
before we had
record low minority unemployment about
5.2 american unemployment was 3.3 it
hadn't been that way since world war
ii in peace time we had a booming
economy
richest oil and gas producer in the
world et cetera et cetera and we shut it
all down
and then we had george floyd's death it
did not matter when you saw that
horrific look of officer shalvin on his
face
it looked that went around the world
with the knee
that was the end of the story if you
said well african americans
12 of them 12 out of 11 million arrests
in the united states last
in the last year we have statistics 2019
12 were shot while unarmed
and police shot more white suspects
and if you look at the number of people
arrested by race versus the number
shot while unarmed lethally by race then
the white uh population who is arrested
is more likely to be
lethally shot by police it didn't matter
so then we had
120 days of rioting and i mean trying to
take over
burn down a federal courthouse in
minneapolis burned down a police
precinct in
portland uh create a whole autonomous
zone in seattle
120 days 2 billion dollars of damage 25
killed 14 000 arrested almost all the
charges either reduce or drop because of
ideological reasons
then we had an election year donald
trump is the most
uh divisive president and the most
radical in
some ways and he was running against
somebody we've never had
a 78 years old and two never campaigned
it was outsourced to the media and his
party but he stayed in his basement as
if he was william mckinley in the 19th
century
never had that happen we never had an
absentee election we had 102 million
ballots cast 63 percent
were not cast on election day either
early voting or mail-in
so the last debate didn't matter because
60 million people had already voted
the error rate usually it's about four
percent
it was that way when we had the last
election it went down to 0.4
so you have all these ballots but
somehow the airway went down so there
were all these questions
then we had this january 6 capital riot
and maybe one of those storms we could
take
but not all of those together in one
year and the people
who had no contact with humans for a
year
just like you and i i don't really know
you i can't see you i can't look at your
intonations
i i have an impression of them and vice
versa of me
if i was in the room it would be a it
would be different so we our suspicions
grow
our paranoias or paranoias you add all
of that proxima
and remote causes and the united states
went stark raving mad
and you people over there in europe and
south america are worried
because whether it's fair or not the
united states is the largest economic
and military power in the world
and it has certain global
responsibilities we may not like them
but we secretly know that they're
important and
if we are woke and the alternative is
china or russian aggression or an
iranian bomb pointed at europe
that's scary and yet we have people in
this country
one of our greatest capitalists uh three
days ago charles monger the
birther hatchway person said he
congratulated what the chinese did to
jack mall it was great
so they just took that sonny and they
said listen sonny you're not going to
operate
here michael bloomberg said china
was a democratic country essentially and
bill gates said they did a terrific
job with cobin so these are very scary
things i think given our position of
responsibility to the rest of the world
francis i think we should call this
episode 10 reasons to be cheerful with
uh professor davis hanson yeah
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
of course
incredible interviews hilarious live
streams
hard-hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline
whatever takes away from your hairline
but if you do love trigonometry and you
want to support us
there's only one place to do that and
that's on locals yes
locals is a brilliant platform that has
been incredibly supportive to our show
and other problematic creators the great
thing about locals
is that it's a community for people who
love trigonometry that's right it's a
place for you to hang out with
like-minded people
share thoughts memes and discuss the
show you can enjoy it for free
but it also gives you the option of
supporting us for
as little as seven dollars a month and
if you want to give more
you can we have incredible rewards for
our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get
in join our community by hitting the
link in the description
and the pin comment below see you there
guys
but yeah i mean we joke about it and i'm
going to use technical language here it
sounds like we're [ __ ]
aren't we well
i thought looking back at the united
states we were screwed in 1933 when we
had 25
unemployment and the house that i'm
sitting in which six generations of my
family have owned i was told when i grew
up
and it wasn't nice in the 1950s it was
kind of [ __ ]
but they had 27 people living here
relatives and they would go each week
down to the train station find another
person starving
and they got i think
it was 31 a ton for 2 000 pounds of
raisins
and that's what they lived on so you
know they made an income about 700
so that was bad and then my family told
me that my father said
i had to fly 40 times over japan and a
b-29 and
we got shot down twice and like crash
landed in iwo jima
and 14 planes in my squadron didn't make
it and you're by the way your namesake
victor hansen was killed on okinawa
first marine division college graduate
and then i would sit around christmas
and then one relative would say hey i
rode with patton right through france
and he got killed and he got killed
and then i'd say to my grandpa who's
belden cather well he was our first
cousin he got shot in the head at
normandy and then somebody would say
a guy at dinner and said well i was up
in alaska fighting the japanese it was
cold it was worse than you guys had it
and that was what i grew up with so
our generation is the most pampered and
leisured in the world
so this is a psychological problem it's
not a material problem
let me just go back so may i push back a
little bit on what you said because
coming back to what we talked about
the erosion of the middle class the
student debt building up the lack of
housing
you can't i mean it's very tempting for
me
and i try not to use the word snowflake
but it is very tempting to say well
these are just these stupid kids
they're they didn't read their history
they don't know about
the history of my country and the evils
of communism and blah blah blah
they're just stupid what they're just
ignorant we need to give them that
information
but but if when if they if the
incentives of the society
they live in don't give them a future
they can look forward to
aren't they right to be revolutionaries
well yes and no it's i don't i hate that
term it's all relative
but in terms of historical or world
poverty no because i teach i see
students
i see people that are living on
winnebagos
on the streets of palo alto right next
by the way to menlo park
uh google amazon all that but what i'm
getting at is
when i see people who are impoverished i
live in southwestern fresno county
where the per capita income is less than
appalachian we're ground zero for
illegal immigration so 95 percent of the
people i see are hispanic
and i go to walmart i'm probably about
the only non-hispanic that goes in most
of the so-called white or asian people
have left
but when i look at the level of
affluence i lived overseas and i had to
get in the line
for 20 minutes to pay 10 dollars to
call home in the 1970s in a terrible
line
these people are calling all over the
world on cell phone i go into walmart
and
i can't believe how inexpensive things
are people are not
uh when we talked about theft in san
francisco
are you suggesting to me that the 10
people that broke into neiman marcus
took those gucci bags and went and ate
them
because they were so hungry no
all right when they went and fenced them
and they took a thousand dollar bag and
got a hundred dollars
so in terms of actual poverty and
deprivation no we're the most pampered
affluent in the world and
and you can survive but second and
here's i think your point
when they see the staggering amounts of
wealth that others enjoy
and they see this worship of mammum and
they look at
esquire and vanity fair and these ads
and they turn on tv and that the cool
people are doing this
and you know dave david geffen is
twittering that i'm uncovered on my 700
million dollar yacht kind of
in isolation ha ha down in the carrot
they don't like that
you know topville said another good
thing i don't want to quote him twice
but he said
people would in a democracy people
the majority would all prefer to be poor
if everybody was equal
in other words they would be willing not
to have it so well if they knew that
everybody else didn't have it so well
if you told them you will have it pretty
well but others will have it really well
they'll oppose that given human nature
who's right about that
so a lot of this anger is i borrowed all
this money
and i got my va in community studies or
i got mine in environmental protection
or i got mine
in race and journalism and guess what i
didn't get
thousand seventy thousand and i need
seventy thousand to buy a house
and a car and to have a suburban life so
yeah they're angry about that
and when they see the disproportionate
wealth
and that's why i think class is a very
important thing
and and i think the left knows that
because the biggest secret is
if you look at the fortune 400 in
america
almost all that wealth is not timber
agriculture steel
mining it is social media internet
insurance law investment we're talking
about
jeff bezos or michael bloomberg
or mark zuckerberg or lisa jobs and
they're all
woke they're all left-wing and you look
at the last election by
zip code and you look at it by
congressional district
all of these blue strongholds
are woke and they're wealthy this is the
biggest secret that these parties have
flipped
the democratic party no longer and i was
a registered democrat my family
were for four generations and i'm an
independent now but the republicans used
to be a country club white guy
golf course caricature they're not now
they are the working class
angry people of all different races
increasingly
and the democratic party is a very
wealthy and the woke and the very poor
and the professional classes and so
this is what's so stunning about it that
the traditional check
on the accumulation of wealth and
monopolies
was the loudmouth left marxist
and media and now they're all part of
that system
that borg and so nobody in the left
they love mark zuckerberg they love
warren buffett they love bill gates
mark zuckerberg gave 500 million dollars
illegally in the sense that you're not
supposed to take private money and
target
precincts in a presidential election to
enhance
voter turnout may drop off boxes for
absentee ballots hiring additional
workers and pre-selected
precincts in swing states to alter the
outcome he did that everybody thought it
was wonderful
but uh that's what's so bizarre about
these times that i always thought the
left was sort of
wow they have two things i grew up with
they're for free
speech and they're very suspicious of
the accumulation of massive amounts of
capital that can lead to monopolies and
now i understand that everywhere i go to
every campus
i speak or where i work on the biggest
enemies of free speech for the left they
just call it
hate speech but professor hansen don't
you think we're
we're denigrating the left to some
extent and i'll explain why because
when we talk about the left we said that
the left is well but nor
not all aspects of the left awoke and
certainly not all aspects of the left
are in support of these huge
conglomerates
like your facebooks or your amazons that
barely pay any taxes
there's plenty of people on the left who
are fiercely critical of these
corporations as they should be
but they're impotent because the if you
just do a little experiment after we're
gone look at
look at very prominent names in the
clinton and obama administration
where did they go after they left and
they find that the most prominent went
to silicon valley
and i lit i work right in there i can
tell you everybody from anita dunn to
the
to the obama epa director they all went
to
apple or facebook so they're part of
that system but
what's what's insidious about it is
your jd rockefeller
or guggenheim or melon or henry ford
today
is mark zuckerberg and the tie-dye we
t-shirt on a surfboard on fourth of july
or he i see them in in downtown palo
alto somebody i'll be walking
to get something and somebody will say
see that guy right there
that guy is worth two billion dollars
i'll say how do you know i said i worked
i used to work for him
or he said that guy was my student he's
worth 500 million what did they look
like they looked
they're indistinguishable from homeless
people and the way they dress cut offs
flip-flops they're cool they're hip
and so it's very hard for the left wing
to consolidate
their anger at them if you look at the
people right now
maybe it's for partisan or or probably
is political reasons but you go to the
u.s congress
look at the congressional record who is
making speeches on the floor the senate
in the house saying we've got to break
up the monopolies
we've got to make them adhere to the
principles of constitution
it's former free market milton friedman
republicans that
have switched and who is defending them
as former
uh you know there's a fed there's a
private enterprise capitalist
octopus that's strangled they're not
that way anymore maybe
elizabeth warren when she's not flipping
houses and writing in one of her books
how to get rich
is still a liberal crusader but i don't
see
any effort on the part of the left at
least in this country to break up
these pernicious monopolies that are
stifling free expression in free speech
because they're too
valuable in promoting a cause that
otherwise would not
enjoy 51 popular support and professor
hanson that therefore leads me on nicely
to the next question which is
therefore all these labels like left and
right become totally redundant they
don't apply anymore
i i agree entirely and that's why i
sometimes have people on the right get
angry at me because i think class i'm
not a marxist by any means i'm kind of a
populist if there's and that's an
in an exact term but i think really that
we've been
fooled by this race race race
deliberately so
i think the left decided somewhere where
in the
in the 21st century that marxism doesn't
work here because of
upward mobility and fluidity yeah and
they thought you know what
we tried it uh the last
guy who was successful at it was bill
clinton
a middle-class agenda but race is
different
because race is immutable and it doesn't
change
and you can be lebron james and worth a
billion dollars and still say the police
are going to kill you or
they're horrible people or they're
murderous even though you have a
security guard up in the la hills
so once you said that oppression
oppressors and oppressed victims and
victimizers are not
based on your actual living conditions
but on the color or the
view of your skin then you had a
permanent
a permanent victim and that's what the
left has done
they've changed all of their ideology
all of the reddick to race race race
race race
they don't talk about clouds and it's
very ironic because of the great society
programs affirmative action
uh if you look at per capita income the
united states
the so-called white majority is not the
biggest income
asians whether that constitutes
americans
or people from india make on average
about 20
000 dollars per capita than so-called
whites that's impossible in a racist
society
and as one of my friends said who's a
punjabi
he said look at me i'm pure black and i
don't feel like a victim
and i said that's because you're a
multi-millionaire
and you you bring up this important
point which i know your upcoming book
deals with which is tribalism and one of
the things that i
scares me about the time that we're in
is i don't think enough people
understand something which i think you
you do
that tribalism is the default setting
for human
beings and the when people talk about
tribalism coming in or happening now
what they don't realize is it's we're
going back
to the default setting and the reason
it's so powerful i think
is that it's very easy to activate these
mental switches on people and to get
people to be tribal
based on things like race sex a little
bit less but particularly race because
we're just pre-wired to do that
it was plato who said that first he said
birds believe it or not he actually said
right birds of a feather flock together
quoting socrates
i have four or five five dogs and i
noticed the queensland
australian catalogs hang out together
and they don't like the labs
and when i look outside i see all of the
morning doves on one wire and the quail
below them
and the hawks hang out together so it's
hard wired in i guess from our
pre-civilization
neanderthal days that we feel more
comfortable with people who
superficially
resemble us so the the work of
civilization was to see that that's a
bad idea
to always hire your first cousin when
he's not qualified
and societies that are merocratic
succeed inside societies that are tribal
don't and that was the great
contribution of rome to the world they
actually invented the word
nation the greeks didn't have it they
had 1 600 city-states
all ethnically there was no hell off
in the sense of a federated nation as
there was with rome that superseded
final
race we did that in the united states
pretty well you
some europeans countries are doing it
are starting to do it better than they
have in the past
and to throw that away for cheap
political gain
is very scary i could show you
campaign speeches on the floor of the
democratic party in 1992
and 1996 by bill clinton hillary clinton
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi when they
were running successfully
successfully against george h.w bush
and bob dole the republicans and they
said things almost verbatim
we are a country of laws we cannot have
the illegal immigration because we can't
assimilate integrate and intermarried
people if you come the united states
come measured
diverse legally and we want you to come
but we cannot
allow hordes to come through
and assimilation to integration is the
vision of martin luther king everybody
understood that
and now we're going we're reverting to a
pre-civilization
mentality it's very scary i noticed that
about five years when i was speaking of
walmart
uh sometime around 2000 the so-called
white and asian
family farmers where i live partly
because of globalization part because of
corporate takeover of agriculture they
left partly because of illegal
immigration and we have a very high
crime rate here
very high so if you were from japan
or korea or armenia or scandinavia or
germany they just
move to the coast or out of state but
there's still a few
so-called white people and i don't know
them very well there's
but if i go to walmart now for the first
time in my life
i've noticed something at about seven
o'clock in the morning to nine there's
about 25 white people in the shoot store
and they're gone and then the the
mexican-american or central american
communities come over
but my point is this when i walk by
white people do this to me hi how are
you
they don't know me i'm thinking why the
hell is he
you know what do i have in common with
this guy i've never met him or somebody
will come up and go
you need help and what they're doing is
they're re-tribalizing
because instinctually they think they're
at the minority now
and they know that you can't say
publicly because
they're still the majority in the
country but in these areas they're
thinking
la raza those guys blm those guys
how am i going to protect our guys even
though some of the we're so intermarried
it's ridiculous we need dna badges to
find out our racial fee days but
i that's very scary because
and i know a lot of african-american
hispanic friends that will tell me
they'll say to me i just had breakfast
with somebody
that was not so called white and he said
to me so when are the white people going
to start this
i said what do you mean he said well
we're doing it but
i said are you worried about it you said
yeah because they're 70
of the population and i said well they
started it remember it's the white
liberal on the coast
that thought this up that we all
identified by a race because
he was so guilty that he never wanted to
live next to a mexican guy
or he didn't want to put his kids in the
public schools so he wanted you know
where i at stanford he wanted castellaia
or sacred heart
or the harker school and he wanted to
live in atherton with
wealthy asians or whites but he didn't
want to live on east palo alto or san
jose
and psychologically this was kind of a
i'm not a big freudian fan but it was an
effort to square the circle of being
uncomfortable with poor people poor
white people poor brown people
and not wanting to hang out with them so
they create the superstructure of
i am so woke look at how they live and
say they're woke they're not
and and so so what you're sort of
alluding to is a lot of this is
basically derived from white guilt
wouldn't you say 100
100 percent they created it this is a
class thing that we're seeing in the
united states and in the western world
in general
i don't see when i talk to
mexican-american people the middle class
here they say to me victor
if we have an open border m13 is going
to come into our schools and they're
going to beat up mexican kids that are
u.s citizens
for three generations that don't speak
spanish as inauthentic
they're going to make us have bilingual
education no advanced placement when my
grandmother wants to go into the
dialysis kalini is going to be crowded
with people
they're not poor and i don't think a lot
of african americans are for it
other than being human and saying if
they're going to give us stuff yeah i'll
take it
but the point is that this was a
phenomenon and
in this country i mean you know better
than i do we were formed by puritans
sometimes they can be very good in their
zealotry of human perfection on earth
the great awakening
the abolitionist movement but often
these americans are self-righteous
sanctimonious
and they're children of the hyper
enlightenment they don't believe in any
religion they don't believe in any
frailty they don't believe in a mystery
they believe that they can solve
every uh question with
the science and so they
they're very judgmental and they've
decided that this is a racist country i
don't know why they decided but i have
my suspicions that when i look at them
and i
see stanford professors or something
they feel
they're not innately racist they just
are culturally
if they see an african-american
professor they're okay with them if he's
in a certain income bracket
he has a certain pathway if they say a
poor black person or middle class
they're they just avoid them and they
feel terrible about it they feel so
terrible
that they're going to go tell uh you
know
bob jones in alabama on a uh
a forklift that he's the problem his
racism
is the problem in america he has nothing
his kids can't get affirmative action
they've never
nobody's been a colleague in his entire
life but he's the problem
no the problem is white wealthy liberals
who will not integrate tutor assimilate
people
there or the other or won't adopt
policies that make it possible to do so
because they're never subject to the
consequences of their own ideology they
have power
influence and they always find a way of
saying
we want everybody to have solar power
but if it's 27 cents a kilowatt that's
your problem down there in bakersfield
where it's 110 we're on the coast or
you know what we don't think water
should go to farmers but we've god
damn it we want that hetch hetchy water
all the way from yosemite for san
francisco they always have this
bizarre way of squaring the circle about
their own privilege
and their own superiority
but they take it out on other people
psychologically
and that makes them feel like they're
woke
that's what woke's all about and we
could solve the race problem with parody
i taught classical languages for 21
years when 75
of the students were not white at
california state university
a third tier and what did i do i started
with the idea that jose was from mexico
he wanted to be in my class he wanted to
be a citizen
and he wanted an education so i said
jose here's what we're going to do
you're going to give lectures on cicero
you're going to learn latin greek you're
going to be able to read french and
german it's going to take you four years
and every time you speak you're going to
speak the king's english perfect grammar
syntax i'm going to correct the grammar
and when i get done with you you will
have a
education but boy
who were the biggest critics of that it
was white liberals in the administration
and the ethnic studies department
and so all of these woke liberals if
they just say to themselves
a hundred people were shot in chicago
there's no
fathers in those homes there's a there's
a teenage
mother's gracing these kids there's no
there's no traditional education
who in that community can i help maybe i
should move there for the summer
let me open an academy let me teach let
me give some of my time
no or if you if you want two million
people coming in and they're in
so-called cages a word that was invented
for four years when trump was present
but
obama created them and biden's using
them then why don't they just say this
we have about two million empty dorm
rooms right now in america
they're at stanford harvard yale texas
or everywhere
nobody no students are in session why
don't we just allow those poor people
coming
to go use university dorms for the
summer you think they're ever going to
do that
no that would raise support for the wall
pretty quick i would imagine i think
we'd have it built
tomorrow listen uh it's been quite a
a let's say a pessimistic conversation a
certain
maybe a realistic title yes let's end on
a high note before we ask you our last
question
what's the solution here what is the
answer how can this be
unwound let's say
i think what we need to do is first of
all
say we're all human and i'm not
going to judge a person by the color of
their skin
but by the content of their character
and i
am not going to feel more comfortable or
less comfortable with a person who
superficially resembles me
a and then b we
are very affluent and we're very blessed
and we're
the luckiest generation in the history
of civilization and we have gratitude to
those who gave us this
and we're not going to desecrate the
past they were they were people in a
pre-industrial age that had to suffer
horrendous physical ailments
poverty and yet we're not going to judge
them by the
the values of the 20th century 21st
century
and then finally we're going to have to
say
there is disparity in this world and
we're going to have to take a greater
look
not at the davos people's great reset
problem
program but on the vast accumulation of
wealth we've never seen anything like
this
herod's atticus and you know second
century
athens didn't quite have all this nero
didn't quite have all this crassus
didn't have
all this so when you have jeff bezos
with 170 billion dollar wealth
and he's controlling all of the
merchandise and commercial
not all but 50 of it in some cases and
the small business person's going out of
business we have to say to ourselves
how do we preserve personal liberty
personal freedom the capitalist private
enterprise private property owning
society and yet
have help for people that are working
hard and we used to think like that that
was
harry truman that was bill clinton that
was dwight eisenhower that was
donald trump they hated him but if you
actually forget all of his excesses and
just think what did he say
it was middle-class middle-class
middle-class working man working man
working man and who hated him
it was a republican silk stalking elite
they hated his guts
professor hansen thank you so much for
coming on the show
we always end our show with the same
question we're gonna have some questions
for our locals patrons afterwards
but our final question for this
interview is always
what is a one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
well we're not talking i i think it's
china and i know people say we talk
about but china
is very different than western europe or
your easter
europe or the united states or the
former british commonwealth
china has 1.4 billion people it's run by
a communist cadre that is linear descent
to mao who killed 70 million people it
currently has about a million and a half
people
in education camps it's destroyed the
indigenous culture of tibet
it's destroyed democracy in hong kong
it's created artificial
islands in the spratly archipelago and
it's got about a hundred new silos at
this building right now as we speak for
intercontinental missiles with nuclear
tips
to hit any target in the world and it's
got a belt road initiative
that is buying off all the choke points
whether it's the panama canal
or suez or the pyreas or
naples in the world and it's very
different than
the west i'm not talking about chinese
tradition i'm talking about the chinese
communist party
and when they take over world leadership
it's not going to be freedom of the seas
it's not going to be the international
criminal court
it's not going to be the united nations
the world bank
international monetary fund it's going
to be
what you see in china today and it's a
scary idea
and there are very brilliant people the
communist party in china and so if you
start the criticism as i just did they
will say
you're a racist and you're
speaking in the long tradition of
western racism against
oriental people they'll use that term
deliberately or they will say
you're jealous or they will say hey
victor
we've got a great billet at a university
in china would you like to write a blog
for us
and we will pay you four hundred
thousand dollars a year if you just do
that
and so they're insidious they being
the communist party and it's cadre i i
speak of somebody who taught a lot of
chinese students they're wonderful
people but every
tenth one was you know pretty much
uh this is a terrible country and we
know that
one one or two percent of the 380 000
here are
engaged in helping the chinese communist
party so
when you have i'll just finish with this
uplifting thought when you have michael
bloomberg saying that china is
pretty much a consensual society
or when charles munger says i'm really
glad that johnny ma
got what was coming to him in china
i mentioned bill gates and you've got
hunter biden who
was getting money from chinese interest
i i don't know
who is invulnerable or who is immune but
the good thing about it is i think it
will draw
europe the united states together i hope
and people all over the world
that are so-called westernized they
believe in a different paradigm than the
communist
party in china because uh
this is orwellian what we're facing and
it's it's
gaining power and clout especially after
the covet
disaster that's a very good point it's
an issue we've covered extensively on
the show but i believe we do actually
have a local's question for you on this
very issue but for the moment
thank you very much for coming on the
show i can't wait to read your book
which is coming out in october
the dying citizen really looking forward
to that and of course thank you for your
time
and thank you all for watching at home
we will see you very soon with another
brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go at 7 p.m uk
time take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe
and hit the bell button so that you
never miss another fantastic episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below